let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 the last opportunity of 2019 to
put your complaints about the david
pakman show on the record as it may be
six one seven eight three zero four
seven five zero let's kick it off today
with our caller from the eight five six
area code caller from eight five six
what's your name where are you calling
from okay this is Aaron from New Jersey
hey Aaron what's going on oh I can't
complain how are you today good thanks
I'm so home today I was wondering um
with the rise of the mutant movement
that we came the Democratic Party
specifically but especially rather go
after men demonizing that oftentimes
when they haven't done anything wrong
and you know especially for someone like
me who is trying to find a girlfriend or
a wife
I feel like this environment that we've
created in a way it's just coming back
to haunt us a lot of times we can't even
go and talk to them and without being
throwing some sort of watchlist or
having some kind of sigh I coming
towards us so I guess my question to you
is what is your advice to someone who in
this environment is seeking someone to
connect with okay so let's explore that
Aaron how old a guy are you
quick 26 okay so your concern as a 26
year old am I correct to to understand
that you're saying you're a heterosexual
male you would conceivably be interested
in dating or marrying a woman right
right you are in a sense afraid of going
to even talk to women because you have
seen other men merely for talking to
women be criticized as either harassing
them or given side i am i understanding
that correctly yes and who would be an
example of a man who talked to a woman
and was accused of of sexual harrassment
for example well I think the most common
example we can that we both know about
be Joe Biden who I've talked to you
about before but really Lucy Flores the
reason that when she was interviewed
when she was asked why she's coming out
about this she's saying oh the only
reason that I came out about all this is
because I want to put burning things in
the White House now see this is exactly
what I'm talking about
where if you don't look a certain way
like it if you don't have a jawline or
six-pack abs or in her case a socialist
agenda or democratic socialist agenda
you you're you're just unclean you're
unthinking we have to go after you and
put you in jail or something right and
Aaron so the example of an alleged
political vendetta being used to
criticize Joe Biden to prop up Bernie
Sanders that affects you as a 26 year
old looking for a girlfriend how again I
think it sees a narrative I think that I
mean I have other examples that I can
throw from my personal life but I think
that like even when I do approach women
a lot of times new I will say hey how's
it going no I think we can both agree
that that's a fairly normal and
appropriate way to greet somebody right
sure oh that would be fine a while ago
like I was getting laid back or you know
maybe we start a conversation but now
people just look at me like I'm scum
like I'm not even worth living this is
interesting so Aaron as a 26 year old
would you say that there was a period
during which you were having a lot of
dating success yeah I would say so I
would say that now things have just
changed - okay but hold on hold on I'm
trying to talk through it
there was a point how old were you when
you would say that when with your hey
how's it going you would go up to women
and it would go really well like how
long ago was that I'd say about four or
five years okay so you were you were
were you in college at the time yeah and
where'd you go to school prominent
universities not too far away but it
wasn't really
the University where this would happen
just you know going out I'm home out of
the parts going for a run so when you
were 20 you would hang out when you were
20 you would hang out at a park and meet
women by saying hey how's it going yeah
you know on the trail you know Aaron I'm
having a hard time believing your story
it sounds very weird what sounds rude
about it it just sounds like you're not
even really sure what it is you're
claiming happened or is happening the
you're you were meeting women at parks
when you were 20 I mean it just it
doesn't it doesn't it all sound a little
bit strange I don't think there's a and
now now where you're getting the bad
looks when you say hey how's it going is
it still happening at parks and
supermarkets or is it happening
somewhere else you know I have gotten
discouraged when I don't do direction
where we're moving the direction where
you'll be positive but hold on a second
Aaron when you first got on the phone
you said that since the me to movement
became prominent when yeah whenever you
go up to women and do this and say hey
how's it going they react as if you're
doing something wrong but then now when
I asked you where that's happening you
said you're not even going up to women
anymore so which is it is that you're
having trouble now when you go up to
women or you're just choosing not to do
it at all because those are two
different things right
well that's discouraged me I don't do a
very good response my advice would be
not to call people up with fake stories
and instead just work on being a normal
person my friend I'm gonna let you go
okay I don't believe any of it okay all
right thanks take care
Aaron from New Jersey